113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 23
what is gain of function research
several weeks ago i started getting a
lot of different emails from people
asking about gain of function research
i've received so many emails that i've
decided to just take
some of the best parts of some of the
best emails and
just combine them into one here and
these chunks of these emails pretty much
cover everyone's questions on the topic
so
hopefully this will be adequate for you
all today's video isn't going to be
quite as
fun as a lot of our videos are here
gain of function research is possibly
the most terrifying
application of the principles of
evolution yet devised
all the information for this
presentation comes from
either publications of scientific
literature or directly from the federal
government
there's been pretty massive and public
debate about gain of function research
ever since it started
arguably it started in 2012. yeah all of
this stuff is online
the documents are fairly lengthy i have
links to everything down in the video
description
the paper that i thought was most
interesting is the white paper the gain
of function research
ethical analysis and i've actually got a
link
to my copy of that which i've
highlighted so you know
it's just a pdf but i've i've saved my
highlights of that for you
in case you're interested in the the
things that jumped out to me
i should point out that i think the
reason there's been so much curiosity
about this recently is actually because
of joe rogan joe rogan's had a bunch of
people
coming on his podcast to talk about gain
of function research
and you know some of what they're saying
is correct some of what they're saying
is not correct
so uh anyway this hopefully will give
you a really solid introduction
so that when you hear the things that
people are saying about this online
a lot of people are trying to link it to
covid uh and so on
this is going to give you a really good
outline of
what's true what's not true what's
important here
again from the perspective of actual
published scientific papers as well as
the
debates that have been published by the
federal government about this because
yeah there have been massive debates
here's just some excerpts from the
letters people have been sending me
i've been hearing about gain of function
experiments where scientists take
viruses from the wild and make them more
dangerous
in the lab is this really happening if
so
why well the answer to that question
unfortunately is
yes and i'll tell you why scientists are
doing that research
during the rest of this video next does
this research really save lives somehow
even still is it worth the risk then it
seems the world is put at risk by these
experiments
even if they do give us new medicines
people in poorer nations will always be
last in line for those new treatments
and then the last letter that i got here
was actually from a
younger kid who's who watches my videos
with his dad
and his dad's actually having him do a
homeschool assignment on gain of
function
experiments and uh his his
letter was kind of funny to read but he
says
my cousin told me they make viruses
inside mutant
mice did you see the mouse with an ear
on its back
yes i did see the mouse with an ear on
its back
and actually as weird as it sounds your
cousin kind of is correct these
experiments are done
on mice that have special mutations that
make them unique for these types of
experiments so yeah
essentially your cousin is correct so
let's dig in here
to gain a function research and let's
start
a little bit back in time before gain of
research became an issue
and look at just virus research in
general
and why it is that there's good reason
to be concerned
this experiment right here published in
science the journal science
is one of the most controversial studies
ever done
and published what these scientists did
is they went on the internet
they looked up the dna sequence for the
poliovirus
and then they built it in their lab all
they had was the sequence
and so they were able to reconstruct the
dna of the polio virus
they were able to get that dna to
function inside of a cell and actually
build the poliovirus
and they had now they had polio in their
laboratory polio is a highly controlled
virus
right only a few research labs in the
world are allowed to have it and study
it
and so they just went online grabbed the
grabbed the dna sequence for it
and just built it in their lab and then
they published it saying hey
this is a problem anyone can do this we
did it in a normal college laboratory
uh maybe we should be concerned about
this and
yeah it raised concern the government
was aware that this stuff
is dangerous it could be used for good
it could be used for evil
and obviously if you're creating
dangerous viruses they can
they can leak out of your lab someone
can get accidentally infected
who works in the lab and then
accidentally spread that
far and wide or of course this could
happen malevolently you could get an
angry researcher who just wants to watch
the world burn
and that person can release it or you
could get an enemy of the state
who bribed somebody or steals something
that this
is dangerous this kick started a debate
about whether or not this type of
research should even be published
whether or not it should be done
and that debate is still raging today
and gain of function is just
another chapter in this debate before
you can really make sense of why it is
that we would ever want to do
gain of function research or any sort of
dangerous virus research it's important
to realize that there is a real threat
of new viruses coming at us from the
wild and from our own farms
what we're seeing right here is a
picture of what is called factory
farming this is how we produce eggs
and meat we have these super farms and
these super farms are really good at
quickly producing large quantities of
meat and eggs and dairy
but you know of course there are animal
rights issues with
the way that we treat animals in these
conditions
and more importantly for today's
discussion these types of farms are
really good
at producing new viruses by accident
now this farm that we're looking at here
is a nice
really well-funded fairly clean farm i
mean obviously the animals
aren't probably being treated very
nicely there they're stuck in tiny
little cages
but there are places that are a lot
worse than this as far as sanitation
goes here's another example
of a farm this is probably one of the
worst examples of an egg farm
where obviously this place is filthy
and new viruses new diseases could be
evolving here
you know in places like this as we speak
people who work in farms like this
often get sick from viruses that would
not ever otherwise jump into humans
because they're these viruses exist in
such high quantities
in these areas people are exposed to
them and every time you have people
exposed to an animal virus
there is a chance that that virus can
evolve and adapt and end up
jumping over into humans and spreading
airborne through humans
but even if that doesn't happen the way
that these farms are set up just allows
new diseases to evolve that can better
infect chickens
and you know if you've got an economy
and a food supply that's based on
massively producing chickens and turkeys
and whatever else if you suddenly
disturb that
food production with a virus or a
disease of some kind you can have
an economic catastrophe i mean your your
whole system can collapse
back in 2015 43 million birds had to be
cold
because of a new virus that evolved
called h5n2
it spread like wildfire in the u.s
through turkeys and chickens
it actually evolved earlier i think it
was first reported in 2005
but 2015 was when it really hit the
poultry industry 43 million birds were
cold
they had to kill them in order to
prevent the further spread of the virus
they killed them and threw them away
just to put that in perspective
the entire state of texas only has 29
million people
who live in that state so we killed
almost twice the population of texas
in birds because of one new virus that
evolved so
that sucked this is a photograph from
the 1918 spanish flu
it killed between 20 and 50 million
people young and old so it was a lot
worse than covid
it was killing everybody it's like
doesn't matter how old you are
they were dropping dead it was
catastrophic just like today everyone
had to wear masks when they went to work
this is a really interesting photograph
this strange device that they had
invented that looks
super super uncomfortable just like
today there were anti-mask
groups and it's really funny how history
repeats itself we all act like this is
the first time we've ever had to deal
with
such horrible violations of our freedoms
but this is actually
a thing that happens every time a virus
breaks out and that 1918
spanish flu we actually believe now was
caused
by farming where people were mixing
chickens and pigs they were farming them
in the same
vicinities when viruses jump from pigs
to chickens and back and forth again
they can actually mutate and evolve and
then gain the ability to infect humans
we don't really do this anymore in
modern factory farms we don't do pigs
and chickens right next to each other
because of this
this is one of the things we learned
from back then but still
what we're doing in our meat industry is
very problematic
and because of that so the argument goes
we need to be doing gain of function
research experiments to understand just
how dangerous things are and what it is
that we should be watching out for
this experiment right here is the one
that really really
kick-started the debate around gain of
function experiments
this research was done at a very
prestigious lab in the netherlands
scientists took a look at a virus called
h5n1
h5n1 is a virus that birds can transmit
to each other through the air so when a
bird sneezes
when it has this flu it can pass that to
another bird
but if humans get this virus they cannot
pass it to each other just by sneezing
people who work with birds
will get this virus from their birds if
their birds have it
so people who work in chicken factories
and so on they can get it
and by the way when humans do get this
virus there's about a 60
death rate so it's extremely extremely
dangerous
not something that you want to get but
it's not transmissible i mean
if you get it you will probably die but
you're not gonna pass it on to your
family members
you're not gonna it's not gonna become a
pandemic so that's good news but
scientists were curious
could it actually evolve to become a
deadly
pandemic could it evolve the ability to
spread from human to human
and so what they did is they actually
tested it out in ferrets humans and
ferrets get each other sick
quite often same with humans and minks
you might have heard that covid has
jumped into minks that's been a big
problem
the reason for that is that we just have
our our respiratory systems are very
similar so what they did in this
research is they took
a strain of h5n1 and they squirted it
into the nose of ferrets and they kept
on doing this
to see if the virus would evolve and
adapt just through the normal process of
darwinian evolution just descent with
modification
acted upon by selection would it evolve
to become an
airborne virus in mammals and sure
enough it did
it took 10 transfers from one ferret to
the next
by you know actually squirting it into
the nose of the ferrets
sure enough it took hold and it could
indeed spread
through the air from one ferret to
another this virus which has
a 60 mortality rate for humans when
humans get it
now because of an adaptation that it
obtained in the laboratory
can spread from mammal to mammal and
probably from human human they didn't
actually try
and see if it could spread from human to
human but it probably could
spread from human to human and so this
was obviously
extremely controversial in fact some
people have said that this might be the
most dangerous virus
known to man right now i mean you have
other things that have
have caused catastrophic deaths in the
past you've got you've got the
smallpox you have the black plague and
black plague's not a virus but for
something with this mortality rate
and the ability to spread like the flu
was the risk
justifiable the answer is maybe
the really important thing that they
discovered was that yeah because of the
way that we currently raise chickens and
turkeys and so on
we could actually have this evolve in
one of our factories
dr fauci back in 2012 was very concerned
with this research he says
the scientists who triggered this debate
have conducted their research
properly and under the safest and most
secure conditions
however similar future research might be
conducted in sub-optimal conditions
in countries or institutions with weaker
infrastructure
or research oversight systems so he was
very concerned that even though
this one was okay everything was
contained
it was done responsibly that's that
might not be how things happen
in the future and i want you to pay
close attention to
the the confidence that fauci has in the
american
and european research facilities right
here that he's displaying because that
confidence is actually going to
uh crumble just two years from now so
that was 2012 that he said this
within two years the the confidence in
the american
and european safety of our virology
institutions
that will that will uh go a little bit
sour as we're about to find out
dr david relman from stanford was very
very upset about this research
he says it is unethical to place so many
members of the public at risk
and then consult only scientists or even
worse just a small subset
of scientists and exclude others from
the decision making
and oversight process in many cases
conversations have only involved
infectious disease researchers
and conflicts of interest among
participants have not been adequately
acknowledged or addressed
it is our responsibility as scientists
to explain
the rationale behind our work including
its benefits and risks
to the general public in terms that are
accessible to those with an
average level of education rather than
to be dismissive
oh hey look that's that's what i'm
trying to do right now this is
especially important when the work
has important consequences for the whole
of society
which is obviously the case with gain of
function research
in spite of the concerns put forth by
fauci and relman
gain and function research did continue
in 2014 this paper was published
called airborne transmission of highly
pathogenic h7n1 influenza virus
in ferrets so again this is a very
similar experiment to the one done
before
people took a chicken disease a chicken
virus
and made it so that it was airborne
transmissible in
ferrets and then probably airborne
transmissible in humans
now again the thing that they discovered
in this research was arguably very
important they showed that the virus can
actually transfer from birds
to mammals in a way that's a lot easier
than we suspected earlier
the earlier experiments that we did it
showed that there was some pretty
complex mutations that had to happen
and it seemed like it was fairly or
somewhat unlikely
that it would happen in just the normal
factory farm setting
but this this experiment showed us that
actually there's more than one way
for the virus to evolve and adapt to
mammals
so some of the people that say that yeah
we we learned some cool things with that
study
but it wasn't really worth it one of
their concerns is the fact that
this research was done at the university
of maryland which
is just you know 27 minute drive from
the white house
it's a major heavily populated area of
the world
and it's only you know 42 minutes away
from an international airport
it seems like it might be a little bit
reckless even though we
we have confidence that our facilities
are really safe
our research facilities why are we doing
this in the middle of a city
why are we doing this next to the white
house why are we doing this next to an
international airport
why why but our laboratories are safe
right so what's the big deal well on
october 17 2014 spurred by incidents at
u.s government laboratories that
that raised serious biosafety concerns
the u.s government
launched a one-year deliberative process
to address the continuing controversy
surrounding so-called gain of function
research on respiratory pathogens with
pandemic potential what happened is that
you know at these
amazing american laboratories top-notch
best in the world there were three
incidences
three accidents that made everyone
question
how safe our labs really are and what
the federal government did
because of that is they halted all of
the experiments that we were doing on
gain and function research
they well they hunt they halted funding
for those experiments
and they immediately said we need to
address this we need to have a
conference about this we need to spend
some time and energy figuring out
whether or not this is worth it
and that's where all these documents and
i've been getting this information from
that's where they come from they were
produced during this time
started in 2014 where people started
meeting about this stuff
but before i go into what was decided at
these meetings
let's talk about these three laboratory
incidences because they're
they're fairly terrifying all of these
three things happened in the year 2014
so workers were exposed to live anthrax
at a cdc lab in atlanta georgia smallpox
was found in a freezer
at a non-secure nih lab in bethesda
maryland again that's near
washington dc smallpox okay smallpox was
found in a freezer just
hanging out there just in some vials and
then h5n1 that really nasty
virus that kills 60 of the people who
get it that was accidentally shipped
from atlanta the cdc's biosafety lab to
a poultry lab
in athens georgia luckily nobody got
sick actually nobody got sick
or hurt during any of these incidences
but
i want you to think about this atlanta
georgia has a csa population
of 6 million people over 6 million
people a csa
population is the not just the
population of people who live in the
city that's like
half a million that live in atlanta but
it's all the people that they have
physical contact with
so the people who drive in and drive out
for
work every day and so on that's the
population of people that would
immediately be exposed to a disease if
it broke out
from one of these labs and in 2019 the
international airport in atlanta georgia
was the busiest
airport in the world isn't this a
problem
like should we be doing this is this
smart
so people started having meetings about
this
during this meeting one of the things
that they did is they outlined
what is gain of function research and
what types of gain and function research
are the most dangerous
and so i'm going to give you their their
more dangerous definition of data
function research
because that term actually applies to a
bunch of things but
they decided that for for the
regulations they're going to put forth
gain of function research is any
virology experiment that increases
the pathogenicity transmissibility or
immune and drug resistance of viruses
in particular viruses that could start
pandemics
there are a lot of viruses that we deal
with that are super dangerous but they
they're not going to start a wide scale
pandemic so this was
specifically for viruses that can be
transmitted
through the air is what they decided for
for the regulations they would end up
coming up with
in layman's terms gain of function
research is any experiment that
makes a virus more dangerous
specifically a virus that could cause
a pandemic so what's the point of gain
and function research the point is to
see how close
a particular virus is to being able to
infect humans
that's what we did with these different
chicken viruses right
another reason to do gain of function
research is to find out specifically how
a virus infects humans this work on
ferrets it actually did show us we could
we could learn exactly how the virus was
getting into ferret lungs
and why it was that it was transmitting
from ferret to ferret
and you know probably would also work
transmitting from human to human
another really cool thing that gain and
function research lets us do is it lets
us test how it is that resistance
to medicines will evolve so if we
develop a medicine
for viruses how will viruses evolve to
adapt
to that medicine and so we do this by
infecting animals with
viruses and then we treat those animals
with our best medicines
and then we see how the virus evolves
and overcomes those medicines you can
also do that to see how the virus simply
overcomes the human immune system
so how frequently will we need to do
booster shots and so on and then
the last big perk of doing gain of
function research
is that it helps us understand the
genotype to phenotype
link in viruses so when we talk about
the genotype of an organism we're
talking about its dna sequence or its
rna sequence as is the case with with
many viruses they have
an rna genome not a dna genome for the
most part we don't really know how it is
that genes code for
traits in an organism including the
traits of a virus
and to figure that out we have to do
very careful research
and some of it falls under the category
of gain of function research we need to
tweak slightly tweak these viruses
slightly tweak their genes
and see what happens and in this process
we could accidentally give them
new functions that we did not intend or
we might actually purposely
give them new dangerous functions
in part so you know we'll look at the
genome of a dangerous virus
and we'll say oh it's got these seven
mutations and we'll take a less
dangerous virus and
one by one will will change its dna to
give it
each of those seven mutations one by one
and see
you know what happens like how is it
that
these mutations cause the ability to
actually become more dangerous and that
is
arguably very important research these
are things that we want to understand
but of course during this process you
might
accidentally spread one of these viruses
that you've made in the laboratory
and that kind of defeats the whole
purpose by the way the reason i have a
bat
on here is because we do a lot of this
research on coronaviruses
and i'm not going to go into that in
depth here because i'll do that in a
future video
on people's concerns that the current
coronavirus that's infecting us
might might have come about through gain
and function experiments
i'm going to talk in depth about that
that needs its own video
you know a lot of people say that that's
just a conspiracy theory others say no
it's legitimate
to really give it the appropriate
attention that it needs i need to do a
whole video just on that and i will
don't worry but that's for another day
so
how is it that that scientists give
viruses new functions how does this
actual research work well
one involves these mutant mice
that one of our viewers was asking about
earlier so i've got a picture of the
mutant mouse with an ear on his back but
one of the ways is is
called serial passage experiments
and we can do these in human cell
cultures or we can do them in humanized
animal models now we don't actually grow
ears
on mice's backs to do these it's not
ears that we use
but we actually use the same type of
mouse that was used in that ear
experiment a lot of people
were confused with that ear experiment
back when it was published they thought
that
scientists had had edited the mouse's
jeans so that the mouse would grow
a human ear that's not what happened
what they did is they
they edited the mouse's genes they
knocked out the genes that it used
to control its own immune system so that
that type of mouse does not have an
immune system and because it doesn't
have an immune system you can grow
all sorts of things inside of it in this
case they grew a human ear
by uh well they used cartilage actually
from cows and they used a scaffolding
that they
it was complicated but the mouse's dna
is not coding for that ear
the only thing they did genetically to
the mouse is they knocked out its immune
system
but we use that same type of mouse and
we actually put
human lung tissue in these mice's skin
and that allows them to be pretty good
models for
how it is that a particular type of
virus will spread in a human lung
believe it or not it actually works as a
fairly good model for the human lung by
just putting a chunk of lung tissue
underneath the skin of a mouse that
doesn't have an immune system
and so that's that is what we do it's
weird but that's what we do
another thing that we do people have
created mice that have
human genes in their lungs so this is
actual gene editing of a mouse
that gives it human lung genes they
still have little mouth-shaped lungs
they don't grow a giant human lung but
they have
receptors on those cells in those lungs
that are the same as the receptors that
humans have
and their lungs and that means that the
diseases that infect those mice can also
infect humans
and they actually behave fairly
similarly in the mouse
the viruses do as they do in humans so
but what do we mean by serial passage
serial passage is what we've been
talking about with the ferrets so what
you do is you take a virus that doesn't
infect humans
very well maybe it's a bird virus or
maybe it's a bat virus a coronavirus of
some kind
and you take one of these humanized
animals
and you squirt the virus either into
their lungs
or the the modified human lung in their
back in the case of the
surgically enhanced mice you squirt the
virus in there in really high
concentrations and even though it's not
very good at getting into
those cells those human cells some of
them will manage to get into those human
cells and cause an infection
then you remove that lung you destroy it
you pull out the viruses
and you inject it into another humanized
mouse and you keep on doing that
until it evolves the ability to really
efficiently infect
human lungs that is what a surreal
passage experiment is
i want to point out here that scariness
aside
it's really cool that evolution is that
powerful
they all we're doing we're they're not
actually doing genetic engineering in
this case
they're just squirting the virus into a
new host and the normal process of
evolution just
darwinian evolution descent with
modification acted upon by selection
that simple process is all it takes
the other type of experiment is chimera
production this is where you take two
different types of viruses
and you inject them into one type of
host when two types of viruses in fact
one type of cell they create kind of
what you could think of as a hybrid of
the virus
through a process of either
recombination or reassortment
flues are really good at reassortment
i'm not going to go into the details of
that what that means but
they're really good at producing hybrids
if two different types of
flu viruses get into one animal and
coronaviruses
are really good at recombination so it's
a different type
of you could call it a hybrid that gets
produced
so one of the things that was suggested
early on for the origin of the
coronavirus
the new one that's been killing people
in 2020
was that a pangolin strain of
coronavirus ended
up mixing with a batch strain of
coronavirus possibly in the
meat market wildlife trade and
that maybe that's where the new virus
how the new virus evolved maybe the new
virus is a hybrid of
pangolin coronaviruses and bat
coronaviruses
and that's still something that's
somewhat considered to be
a possibility now but it seems to have
fallen out of popularity
among different researchers but that's a
process that can also be done in the
laboratory by infecting
one animal with two different strains of
a virus and then you have what's called
reverse genetics which often involves
lab induced recombination and this is
where you use genetic editing techniques
to really
fine-tune what you're doing and what
types of modifications you're making
to the genome of a virus this book right
here is a summary of a workshop that
federal government put on back in 2014
to really discuss and debate the
potential risks
and benefits of gain of function
research obviously it's dangerous
the risks of course are accidental leak
of an enhanced strain of virus something
that
maybe might not ever evolve in the wild
but certainly could evolve
or be engineered in the lab these
viruses could be
released not just accidentally but also
on purpose through malevolent
actors and there actually have been
cases in the past of people who are
angry at their bosses or whatever in
laboratories and they will
purposely infect their boss or one of
their co-workers they'll purposely
infect their
personal protection equipment and end up
killing somebody that's happened before
in labs just human nature we do messed
up things from time to time so this
could
be like just a bad guy that works in the
lab that could do this
or it could be an actual terrorist group
that's
you know bribing someone or threatening
someone
or actually just breaking into a
facility and stealing stuff you know in
the past we've had animal rights
activists who go in and
destroy laboratories or people who are
just upset about the type of research
happening in a laboratory the
people go in and destroy a laboratory or
try to release the animals
that of course you know if it's the
wrong laboratory that could cause a
pandemic
so that's dangerous the fact that we
publish data when we discover it
that could be used by terrorists to
create their own deadly viruses
and then of course these experiments
provide opportunity for the evolution of
unpredicted capabilities you know in a
laboratory you've got all sorts of cell
cultures
from all types of different animals
you've got different lab animals that
have been
mutated in a bunch of different ways if
you were to have a virus not escape the
laboratory but just escape
a specific experiment and start
infecting other cells that you have in
culture
and other animals and so on you can have
a situation where it's evolving and
adapting rapidly
to all sorts of different organisms
because you have all these different lab
animals and all these different cell
cultures in your laboratory
insane things could happen in this
scenario
just like who knows what's going to end
up evolving
in these cases so this is this is really
dangerous now
in like a top level biosecurity lab
all of the animals are always treated as
if they're infected it's
they kind of treat all the animals at
these laboratories as if they are loaded
guns
right but still it's a dangerous
scenario that we're we're we've created
for ourselves here they noted that with
some exceptions of influenzas
enhanced viruses are not usually as bad
as the most dangerous
current wild strains of viruses this
means that gain of function research is
usually no more dangerous than research
on wild type
strains wild viruses that said
unexpected traits can develop
during gain of function research and of
course
they talk about the potential benefits
gain of function research is often the
only way to determine how a virus
functions there's just not many other
good ways
gain of function is often the only way
to see how a virus adapts to treatment
if you have a treatment that works but
you're worried that the virus might
evolve a way to avoid
that treatment gain and function
research really is the only way to do
that and then gain and function research
tells us
which wild strains are close to spilling
over spilling over into human
populations gain of function research
allows us to study
the genotype phenotype link the hope
with
gain of function research is that
someday we'll we'll understand viruses
so well
that we won't need to do gain of
function research ever again
because we will understand perfectly how
it is that genotype
determines phenotype in viruses and so
we'll be able to just
take a sequence of dna or rna pop it
into a computer
and that computer will tell us whether
or not this can infect humans
if it can exactly how it does it how
transmissible it'll be and so on but
we are definitely not able to do that
right now we are a long long way
from that type of knowledge but it's
argued that gain of function research
might eventually help us
get there during this meeting they asked
whether or not there are safer
alternatives
because you know why would you do the
dangerous thing if there's a safer thing
you can do instead
and they pointed out that pseudotyping
is one of these pseudotyping is where
you take
a virus that's completely benign to
humans and you just add
part of the dangerous virus that you
want to study so maybe you just want to
put the spike protein the outer
protein that the virus uses to get
inside of human cells into
a safe virus and you do that through
genetic engineering tricks it was
pointed out that while
that can help us understand a lot it's
not nearly as effective as studying the
entire virus because
the whole is greater than the sum of its
parts then of course there is
large-scale comparative studies of wild
viruses
instead of setting up weird scenarios
where a virus is guaranteed to evolve to
adapt to humans
you could just collect lots of viruses
in the wild
see what they do when you put them in
human cells can any of them
get into human cells and if they can you
just look at well how did they do it
what's different about them than these
other ones that can't do this
you know what what are the specific
mutations that we think that we can
correlate
to you know entry into human cells
entry into human respiratory systems so
that's an alternative but
as it was also pointed out that's that's
still pretty dangerous so
it's not that much safer than gain of
function research
and then to combat the the issue of you
know terrorists
using this type of information to create
a disease is when we publish these
journals
when we publish our research we don't
have to tell people everything
we can tell them the main findings but
we don't have to give them like the gene
sequence
of the deadly virus we don't have to
tell them that the step-by-step
recipe that the things that we did to
make it we don't have to give them that
information
but you know to be honest the
information that's already published
online is pretty
pretty freaking dangerous it actually
might be a little bit too late for this
anyways
so that's those are the things that they
discussed everything from that initial
meeting plus
a lot more eventually went into this
risk and benefit analysis of gain and
function research that was published in
2016
from that we have new guidelines for
what it is that the federal government
will and will not
fund those new guidelines came out in
2017.
also from all of that some new agents
were added to the cdc's select agents
and toxins list this is the list of
things that
if you are messing with them in your
laboratory you will go to prison
for a very long time if you're caught
without proper
authority from the federal government
and they added to that sars associated
coronaviruses so you can't do these
things unless a lot of people in the
federal government know exactly what
you're doing
since 2017 there are two big projects
that have been approved it's not
super clear if either of these projects
are doing gain of function research but
they are doing
risky research on very dangerous
pathogens
and they they do have approval so where
does this leave us
i think
this is such a complex problem
i do understand the value in this
research it really does help us
understand how viruses work
and at this moment in history i think
that it's probably really important that
we understand
better far better how viruses work the
kova 19 pandemic has been a
huge advertisement to terrorists saying
hey if you want to screw up the world
make a virus and let it loose i
would not be surprised if sometime in
the next 10 years we're going to see a
real attack
and in order for us to combat such an
attack we need to understand how viruses
work better
than we do right now and one of the best
ways to
understand how viruses work really is
gain of function research
aside from that possibility of terrorist
groups we also have factory farming
expanding like never before
the human population is butting against
bat populations
all around the world the chance of a new
really nasty virus just evolving
naturally
is also extremely high higher than it's
ever been in the past
just because our population is so large
now and so well connected
we really do need to understand how
these viruses work but we need to find a
way to do it safely
maybe one option is to start sunsetting
these laboratories that exist in
atlanta georgia these major cities and
start building out
in deserts somewhere where employees
will you know go in
and you know come into work work there
for several months
then quarantine then go back to
civilization spend a couple months off
and just worked things out like that
because the risk
just seems too high so i would love to
see an open debate
started again i know that we just had
this from 2014 to 2017 but i think we
need to do it again
i think we need to do it again in light
of the coven 19 pandemic
i think that it's fair to say that
virology research is now
as dangerous as nuclear research viruses
are just one more thing that science has
given us that we now have to constantly
be worried about we need to we need to
be responsible with this information
that we've gained
and it's not going to be easy that's
unfortunate
but it is true so sweet dreams everyone
stay curious next question